[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen ihnen allen zum
Nachrichtenüberblick an diesem Samstag
die vom Sport hat Norbert König ja guten
Abend wir haben unter anderem diese
Themen für sie
feiern mit Sorge die Ukraine jubelt über
die Befreiung von Carson aber Beobachter
warnen jetzt könnte Russland die Stadt
aus der Entfernung bombardieren
werben um Freunde US-Präsident beiden
Umgang die aufstrebenden Staaten in
Südostasien und konkurriert dabei mit
China
und hätte schief gehen können in Köln
drängen sich zum Auftakt der
Karnevalssaison viel zu viele Menschen
auf viel zu wenig Raum
[Musik]
wir beginnen in der Ukraine die ihre
militärischen Erfolge feiert von der
südlichen Region herson sind zwar immer
noch 70 Prozent unter russischer
Kontrolle aber die gleichnamige
Regionalhauptstadt ist wieder frei
und das bejubeln Menschen in vielen
Städten im Land herson gilt vielen
Ukrainern als Symbol im Kampf gegen das
übermächtige Russland im Netz kursieren
Videos mit Soldaten die in Person
Wassermelonen geschenkt bekommen die
Frucht ist das Markenzeichen der Region
von dort berichtet unsere Tochter Dara
Hassan
oberung hersons war auch ihr Tag es wird
Lana ivanifna die Krankenschwester ist
dort geboren ihre gesamte Familie lebt
den reison monatelang war sie in Sorge
oft gab es über Tage keinen Kontakt
jetzt fühlt auch sie sich befreit
gestern übermannt ich habe einfach
geweint vor Erleichterung ja ehrlich
ich habe immer gehofft und geglaubt dass
Herr Sohn befreit wird die Besatzung war
für mich einfach nur ein Wahnsinn
sie muss sich weiter gedulden noch
verwert das ukrainische Militär den
Zugang wegen Minengefahr wir fahren in
die Provinz herson so weit wie es uns
erlaubt ist am Wegesrand Dörfer schon
vor Wochen befreit doch wie die Stadt
herson immer noch in Reichweite der
russischen Artillerie
Sergej ist Handwerker auf Wunsch der
Eigentümer macht er die Häuser nur
provisorisch winterfest erst in der
vergangenen Nacht wurde das Dorf wieder
bombardiert nicht nur das dämpft seine
Euphorie
meine Schwester wohnt gegenüber von Herr
sol auf der anderen Seite der Brücke sie
sitzt seit Monaten im Keller
sie haben Kontakt über Skype Telefone
gehen nicht dort gibt es nur russisches
Handynetz
im Dorf erinnert man sich noch gut an
den Rückzug der Russen aber man weiß
auch dass nach Tagen der Freude die
Sorgen des Krieges wiederkehren werden
fragen wir darauf Hassan sadi vor Ort
wann können die aus herson geflüchteten
Menschen zurück in ihre Heimat
ja heute ist zumindest schon mal die
ukrainische Polizei und die territoriale
Verteidigung in herson eingerückt und
sie wird sich um genau darum kümmern
eine möglichst schnelle Rückkehr für die
Zivilisten vorzubereiten es muss entmint
werden dass sie die Entbindung muss
abgeschlossen werden die Infrastruktur
muss überprüft werden gibt es genug
Wasser gibt es genug Strom funktionieren
die Krankenhäuser und dann gibt es
natürlich noch die große Frage wie sieht
die Reaktion Russlands aus die letzten
vier Wochen hat Russland immer massiv
die Infrastruktur in der Ukraine
bombardiert und Person könnte jetzt das
Ziel werden Dankeschön für diese
Einschätzung aus privi Dara Hassan city
jetzt nach Kambodscha zu einem wichtigen
weltpolitischen Treffen der Verband
südostasiatischer Länder kurz Asian hat
zum Gipfel geladen heute reiste der
US-Präsident an beiden geht es darum den
wachsenden Einfluss Chinas in der Region
einzudämmen mit den asian-staaten
vereinbarten die EU die USA jetzt eine
so wörtlich umfassende strategische
Partnerschaft MRT wissen ist für uns
dabei in der kambodschanischen
Hauptstadt von pompen welches Ziel hat
diese strategische Partnerschaft
ja Joe Biden baut hier gewissermaßen die
Bühne für sein erstes direktes
Zusammentreffen mit dem chinesischen
Präsidenten Gigi in Ping am kommenden
Montag diese strategische Partnerschaft
mit den asian-staaten umfasst eben
Investitionen in die Infrastruktur hier
in dieser Region den Ausbau der
digitalen Vernetzung auch eine
militärische Zusammenarbeit für die
Staaten die die wirtschaftlich und
militärische Dominanz von China in der
Region zunehmend fürchten und das soll
offenbar eine klare Ansage sein an
Peking dass die USA eine pazifische
Großmacht sind und bleiben die
Bündnispartner hat in der Region und
ihnen auch den Rücken stärkt die
politischen Beziehungen zwischen China
und USA sind ja ziemlich am Tiefpunkt
und deswegen will man am Montag mit
shisha-ping über rote Linien reden und
Mechanismen finden die man Konflikte
künftig lösen kann um Eskalationen zu
vermeiden und erst wenn das geklärt ist
so ist jedenfalls die Hoffnung der
Amerikaner kann man dann auch über
Themen reden bei denen man vielleicht
zusammenarbeiten kann und will mit China
Wissen live aus pompen dankeschön
eine Nachricht aus der Heimat dürfte den
US-Präsidenten gefreut haben bei den
Zwischenwahlen haben seine Demokraten
einen der letzten umkämpften Senatssitze
den in Arizona erobert nach tagelanger
auszählt Zitterpartie setzte sich
Amtsinhaber Mark Kelly durch das erhöht
die Chance der Demokraten die Mehrheit
im Senat zu halten zwei Sitze die von
Nevada und Georgia sind noch offen
nicht nur in den USA hat Twitter für die
politische Meinungsbildung eine große
Bedeutung vor zwei Wochen kaufte Tech
Milliardär Elon Musk den
Kurznachrichtendienst seither herrscht
dort Chaos mask feuerte die Hälfte
seiner Mitarbeiter wichtige Werbekunden
kündigten jetzt schließt der reichste
Mann der Welt eine Pleite von Twitter
nicht mehr aus Jutta sonnewald hat mehr
Elon Musk scheint unberechenbar jeden
Tag erreicht er sich mit neuen oft
widersprüchlichen Aussagen und Tweets
Aufmerksamkeit eben noch warnt er die
twitter-belegschaft vor einer Insolvenz
im nächsten Moment prophezeit er ihnen
eine blühende Zukunft die wunderbare
Ironie der Situation ist dass die Medien
die pausenlos über Twitter und mein
Versagen schreiben ein massives Wachstum
bei Twitter bewirken schreibt er die
Zahlen sprechen eine andere Sprache
Twitter verzeichnet enorme
Umsatzeinbrüche für den Kauf der Social
Media Plattform hat der Tech Milliardär
einen hohen Kredit aufgenommen Banken
zweifeln ob er die Zinsen von jährlich
über einer Milliarde Dollar noch stemmen
kann
die Banken die mask bei der Finanzierung
geholfen haben werden wahrscheinlich bis
zu einer Milliarde Dollar durch die
Schulden verlieren für die Banken ist
dieses Geschäft ein absolutes Desaster
große Werbekunden haben sich von Twitter
zurückgezogen weil Hetze rassistische
Beleidigungen und Fake-Accounts in der
letzten Woche rasant zugenommen haben
der Grund nach der Entlassungswelle von
etwa Hälfte der Twitter Belegschaft
können solche Dinge nicht mehr schnell
genug entdeckt und gelöscht werden
je größer der Zirkus im twitter wird
desto größer ist die Gefahr dass sich
das auch negativ auf die Marke Tesla
auswirkt
gestern haben weitere Top-Manager
Twitter den Rücken gekehrt die beiden
Sicherheitschefs und der
Datenschutzbeauftragte das twitter-chaos
hat nun die us-verbraucherschutzbehörde
FTC auf den Plan gerufen sie warnt
sollte Elon Musk sich nicht an
Vereinbarungen zum Datenschutz und
Sicherheit halten drohen Twitter
milliardenstrafen
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat das brutale
Vorgehen der iranischen Regierung gegen
Demonstranten scharf verurteilt wer auf
die eigenen Bürgerinnen und Bürger
schießt der muss mit unserem Widerstand
rechnen so Scholz auch verteidigte er
die geplanten neuen Sanktionen der EU 30
Personen und Organisationen soll das
Vermögen gesperrt und die Einreise
verweigert werden
2030 kommt der Kohleausstieg in
Nordrhein-Westfalen trotzdem soll vorher
noch der Ort lützerath abgerissen werden
dagegen haben heute mehr als 1.000
Menschen demonstriert in Lutzerath haben
Aktivisten geräumte Häuser besetzt sie
wollen das Abbaggern von 280 Millionen
Tonnen Braunkohle im Tagebau Garzweiler
verhindern zur Kundgebung hatte ein
Bündnis aus Umweltverbänden und
klimapolitischen Organisationen
aufgerufen
Deutschland will und muss weg von den
fossilen Energien doch gerade beim
Heizen gibt es noch viel aufzuholen erst
rund 15 Prozent der Wärme werden
regenerativ erzeugt mehr könnte aus
Geothermiekraftwerken kommen dabei
werden oft tausende Meter tief
thermalwasserreservoirs Angebot das
heißt Wasser erhitzt frisches
Grundwasser das wird dann in die
Haushalte gepumpt kalt fließt es zurück
ins Reservoir wo es sich langsam wieder
aufh kann was damit in Deutschland
möglich wäre zeigt in arabe
schweres Gerät sogenannte
vibrations-trucks suchen südlich von
München nach Standorten für große
erdwärmekraftwerke durch Vibrationen
wird gemessen wieder Untergrund bis in
5000 Metern Tiefe aussieht wichtige
Daten für die Nutzung der sogenannten
Tiefengeothermie alle sind sich einig
dass das Potenzial der Tiefengeothermie
in Deutschland mindestens 25% des
gesamten Wärmebedarfs beträgt bis jetzt
trägt Geothermie nur zu einem Prozent
zum Heizen bei wenn man das auf rund ein
Viertel aller Gebäude ausweiten will
braucht es mehr Infrastruktur und mehr
geothermie-
überall hier ist
tiefengeothermietechnisch möglich im
norddeutschen Becken dem Oberrheingraben
und im sogenannten Molassebecken der
Rest von Deutschland ist noch nicht
hinreichend erforscht gebohrt wird auch
inzwischen in Hamburg mitten in der
Stadt im Rheingraben bei Landau und Kehl
dagegen haben Bohrungen Erdbeben
ausgelöst die Projekte wurden
eingestellt
wir können im Vorfeld nie eine 100%
Garantie geben das ist nicht vielleicht
ein größeres Baby gibt ausgelöst durch
die Anlage aber wir haben sehr dazu
gelernt die Verfahren werden immer
besser im Großraum München sind die
Erfahrungen mit der tiefen Geothermie
gut seit 2009 gibt es dieses
fernwärmekraftwerk in Unterhaching es
versorgt 7000 Haushalte mit Wärme schon
mal die Hälfte der Gemeinde
ist Geothermie die Lösung dieser Frage
geht eine Dokumentation nach morgen um
15 Uhr im ZDF oder schon jetzt in
unserem Mediathek
Deutschland zuerst unter diesem Motto
hat der Thüringer
afd-fraktionsvorsitzende Björn höcke und
etliche rechte Gruppierungen für heute
nach Erfurt vor den Landtag geladen zu
Spaziergang und Kundgebung doch es kamen
sehr viel weniger Teilnehmer als
angekündigt über den Tag in Erfurt mit
Demo und Gegendemos berichten Melanie
Haag und Daniela Sonntag
angemeldet waren 10.000 gekommen sind
laut Polizei nur 2000 rechte und
rechtsextreme Bewegungen wie pegida
freies Thüringen die AFD haben
aufgerufen die Sprache radikal und die
Scharlatane aus ihren Palästen jagen sie
vor gerichtstellen und nach den
Prozessen richten dass sich die
Rechtsextremen Akteure ausgerechnet vor
dem Thüringer Landtag versammeln sei
kein Zufall so Thüringens Innenminister
aufgrund der Vernetzung die jetzt hier
offensichtlich stattfindet aber auch
natürlich der Ort hier direkt vom
Parlament ja das ist natürlich ein
symbolischer Ort
wir haben die Szenen noch vor Augen
heißt Tag Capitol und so weiter das ist
natürlich ganz bewusst gewählt zwei
Kilometer entfernt gegen Kundgebung das
Erfurter Bündnis auf die Plätze hat
aufgerufen unterstützt von Linkspartei
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und der Initiative
Omas gegen Rechts Protest gegen Hass und
Hetze das Unsagbare wird insagmare
verschoben es wird offen jetzt
gesprochen über den Systemen Umsturz und
Leute wir müssen unsere Demokratie jetzt
wirklich standhaft verteidigen zur
Stunde ziehen beide Demonstrationen
durch die Stadt die Polizei ist mit
einem Großaufgebot vor Ort
nach Köln dort geriet der
Karnevalsauftakt gestern so aus den
Fugen dass man wohl froh sein muss dass
in dem Chaos nicht mehr passiert ist die
Innenstadt war binnen kürzester Zeit
völlig überfüllt der öffentliche
Nahverkehr musste eingestellt werden
jetzt wehrt sich die Stadt gegen Kritik
an ihrem Sicherheitskonzept aus Köln
Kerstin Edinger
sie strömten in Massen Ausnahmezustand
gestern im Zülpicher Viertel
karnevalsjacken aus ganz Deutschland
kamen nach Köln schon früh musste der
einzige Zugang zur Feiermeile
geschlossen werden
und kurz vor zwölf gab es schon großes
Gedränge an der Sperrstelle am Eingang
Südbahnhof wir sind da gerufen worden
wir haben da auch dann die Stadt
unterstützte Sicherheitskräfte die
Polizei rückte mit einer Hundertschaft
an um die Feiernden und trinkenden
Jugendlichen umzuleiten zu viele auf
engstem Raum die Wirte sind beunruhigt
man kam einfach durch die Masse nicht
mehr durch auch wenn man stabil und
energisch ist nicht mehr das war
brandgefährlich wenn da irgendwo ein
Auslöser für eine Massenbewegung gewesen
wäre hätten wir hier sehr wohl zwei
bekommen Soul an Halloween kam es dort
zu einer Massenpanik mit mehr als 150
Toten Forderungen nach einem neuen
städtischen Sicherheitskonzept in Köln
werden nun laut das muss weit
dezentralisiert werden und hier hat es
nicht mehr so statt zu finden die Stadt
Köln will die Lage nun auswerten dann
wird man dieses Gesamtbild anal und eben
mit Blick auf den Straßenkarneval der ja
in wenigen Monaten dann auch schon
ansteht wird man dann prüfen ob und in
welchen Bereichen eventuell
Nachbesserungen erforderlich sind und
das muss schnell passieren in 14 Wochen
wollen hier alle wieder Karneval feiern
[Applaus]
jetzt Tennis Norbert die deutsche
Spielerin bleiben erstklassig im Team
ganz genau sie haben im Billie Jean King
Cup das ist der frühere fettcup 3:1
gewonnen im Playoff Spiel gegen Kroatien
Anna-Lena friezam hat mit einem
zweisatzerfolg gegen Petra matschinko
den entscheidenden dritten Punkt geholt
nachdem zuvor Jule Niemeyer ihre
Niederlage von gestern vergessen ließ
sie hatte als deutsche Nummer eins nach
ihrem enttäuschenden Auftritt gestern
einiges gutzumachen und das gelang Jule
Niemeyer gegen Anja konju gegen die sie
bei zwei Niederlagen noch nie zuvor
gewinnen konnte mit dem souveränen 6:1
und 6:2 sorgte sie im dritten Einzel
gegen Kroatien für die deutsche
2:1-führung
Teamchef rainer Schüttler nominierte
dann überraschend für die gestern
erfolgreiche Eva ließ die erfahrenere
Annalena frizam die wird zur Bestätigung
gegen Petra marcinko glatt in zwei
Sätzen gewann damit lag das deutsche
Team nach vier einzelnen uneinholbar mit
3:1 in Führung und gehört damit auch im
kommenden Jahr zur Weltgruppe im Billie
Jean King Cup
sie können wieder lachen nach schwacher
erster Gruppenphase hat sich die
Handball-Nationalmannschaft der Frauen
die Chance aufs Halbfinale der
Europameisterschaft bewahrt gegen die
Niederlande die Weltmeisterinnen von
2019 gelang im Skopje ein überzeugender
und klarer Sieg mit 36 zu 28 noch zwei
weitere Erfolge dann könnte es mit Glück
für die medaillenrunde Reichen
die Bochumer Fußballprofis können schon
wieder jubeln mit dem ersten
Auswärtssieg der Saison hält der VfL
Anschluss an die Konkurrenz
erzielte den Treffer zum 1:0 in Augsburg
auch Hertha BSC holt unten drei Punkte
2:0 gegen Köln Leipzig sechster
Pflichtspielsieg in Folge 2:1 in Bremen
Wolfsburg seit 1 Oktober ungeschlagen
2:1 in Hoffenheim und Leverkusen
Stuttgart 2:0 am Abend Schalke Bayern
ausführlich im Aktuellen Sportstudio um
23 Uhr gestern Gladbach gegen Dortmund
4:2 morgen zwei Spiele dann Winterpause
Leipzig ist und bleibt weiter hinter den
Bayern falls Freiburg und Union
unentschieden spielen Dortmund zurück
auf 6 vor Wolfsburg Werder 9 unten nur
zwei Punkte Differenz zwischen Augsburg
und Bochum Schalke nehme bei einer
Niederlage gegen die Bayern 4 Punkte
Rückstand mit in den Januar also
nächster Bundesliga Spieltag mit dem
Fernglas
Dankeschön Norbert zum Schluss noch mal
in die Ukraine und zu dem wohl
bekanntesten unbekannten der Welt der
britische Streetart-Künstler Banksy hat
sich in der Stadt borotianca verewigt
man muss allerdings schon genau
hinschauen auf der Wand eines zerstörten
Hauses macht ein Mädchen Handstand zu
dem Werk hat sich der Künstler schon
bekannt und auch dieses Bild ganz in der
Nähe sieht verdächtig nach einem Banksy
aus
das Wetter morgen bringt mehr Sonne und
weniger Nebel die Details hat gleich
Christa Orban um Viertel vor elf begrüßt
Sie Marietta Slomka im heute-journal und
wir danken für Ihr Interesse und
wünschen Ihnen noch einen schönen
Samstagabend bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend es gab heute wieder große
Temperaturunterschiede im Nebel am
Münchner Flughafen 5 Grad mit Sonne und
leichtem Föhn rund um Aachen 19 Grad
außerdem ist die Luft in der Höhe im
Moment sehr mild auf dem Feldberg im
Schwarzwald 14 Grad im zum Vergleich in
Freiburg nur 7 Grad auch in der Nacht
gibt es Temperaturunterschiede die Werte
sinken meist auf 8 bis 3 Grad bei klarem
Himmel können Sie aber auch auf -3 Grad
zurückgehen und verbreitet gibt es in
der Südosthälfte dann auch Bodenfrost
dazu breitet sich der Nebel in der Mitte
und im Süden weiter aus im Norden gibt
es weiter diese Kombination aus
nebelhochnebel und tiefen Wolken die
sorgt morgen dann dafür dass es östlich
der Elbe grau bleibt im Westen scheint
aber schon vormittags die Sonne und
dazwischen kann sich der Nebel tagsüber
auflösen denn der Wind weht spürbarer
als heute und so gibt es auch morgen in
der Mitte und im Süden weniger Nebel als
noch heute trotzdem kann drüber rein
oder am Bodensee und der oberen Donau
zäh bleiben abgesehen davon ist es aber
ein sonniger Sonntagmorgen und das meist
bei 10 bis 15 Grad im Nebel ist es etwas
kühler in den höheren Lagen aber auch
etwas milder das schaffen wir dann in
der neuen Woche nicht mehr und auch wenn
es am Montag im Norden noch viel Sonne
gibt dann wird es aus Südwesten
wechselhafter tschüss